hello everybody my name is I can sign
and welcome to comic-con 2013 hey guys
I'm currently at comic-con and these are
the voices of the fans that have been
nice enough to come up and say hi to me
so if you want to say hi to me and get
in the V log say hi to me okay
alright alright okay here we go here we
go alright ready yes ready for this yeah
gonna do to do it alright alright what's
your name again Jesse Jesse
well I'm good this guy's name's mark
what's your favorite thing about Mark
Clark his name is Mark and my name is
Mark good reason good reason to love
someone
thank you goodbye okay so what's your
favorite thing about mark Claire Claire
why do you think Mark Guyer is so great
this makes awesome videos it makes you
laugh good job
what's your favorite thing about martin
surgeon simulator that games over oh
you're gonna unsubscribe now
no no more observational it is more I
don't know if there'll be more there
will be more updates and maybe I can
actually make a video where I beat
surgeon simulator 2014
maybe but that's so long from now I'll
probably be dead cool what's your
favorite thing about me I could play I
would have to say face you thanks so
much
my beautiful face are you funny okay
yeah alright what's your favorite thing
about markiplier the sexy voice it's six
things there what's your favorite thing
about my channel really that's your
that's your favorite thing okay you
don't like like the videos I don't like
those videos or crap I pretty much
agreed pretty much every man's come-up
me send my videos a crop so thanks
anything else
I'm the greatest ever by Christian by
what's your favorite thing about
markiplier
my favorite thing about markiplier is
the the horror reactions it's amazing
they are amazing I'm amazing love it I'm
the greatest ever oh and he's here too
what's your name Tom um so thanks Tom
for being said hi everybody this is
Emily breeze Bach hi hi hi this is my
first moderator on twitch chat don't
don't freak out just yet so any what's
your favorite thing about markiplier my
favorite thing about Mark Pryor is how
wonderful and humble he is he never
boast he never brags it never gets in
your face he never does anything
irritating on camera know what well you
were saying oh yeah thank you so much so
those were just some of the people that
came up and said hi to me but there's
still a long way to go at Comic Con I'm
still going to be here and if you want
to find me I'm gonna be at the Keane
spot booth you can find it right right
right right right right right here in
between image and Marvel number two six
three five right here in this general
area on the comic-con show floor so here
you can find out where the greatest
entertainment is going to be in comics
not marble by the way screw marvel
they're over there images over there
we're the important one in the middle
where
see that so anyway thank you guys so
much who has come up to me so far and
then we'll see you down here bye bye